what did we do yesterday they focused
upon developing those parametric
equations for the different conic
sections okay now today we're going to
come back to focusing on the ellipse
right and the parametric equation for
the ellipse x equals y equals R or you
remember is so much like this circle
right it's so much like the circle the
only difference is that there's
different proportions horizontally and
vertically right so what we're out how
much equal zero because they don't and
be safety not excellent okay now what is
the point of introducing a parameter as
we met you know the parametric of a
parabola right number one you get this
nice way of saying I could define any
point of combining Marcus just with a
single number rather than we to know
this okay
and secondly it makes particular kinds
of questions feel kinds of geometry
easier to deal with
okay easier to deal with easier to
express easier to articulate okay I
think I sort of tease some of that
before tangents balls and chords are
gonna be the mating the primary example
of things that this unlocks it a bit of
an easier way okay we're not going to do
quads today probably we'll see how you
go depends how much time we gather the
exercise but what I'm gonna show you is
how to develop the equation for the
tangent and then the normals to the
ellipse we're gonna do it both ways
we're gonna parametrically using this is
our basis okay and then we're also going
to develop it in cartesian equations
just so you can understand you actually
need to have both those there but you
will see quite rapidly
how about how far superior this is in
most places all right so just really
quickly for me for the sake of
illustration draw an ellipse let's get
the picture Internet
he's the scenario talk me out and have a
mess
very very standard ellipse and based on
some angle measured from the positive
x-axis up to like using that that it's
not a radius you see that interval that
goes up to the point on the markets that
we're at so I'll forward that we have
these parametric equations which give us
a way to express the coordinates at this
point right because FINA B so under here
now we could draw like what are we
trying to find we're trying to find a
general expression for what's the
equation of the adjustment to the
tangent at that point at any point P for
any value theorem okay now let's just
think about this if I know where the
point is what other piece of information
I only leave one will give me an
equation of the tape I just integrate it
and then I'll pop it into quite radiant
form
why don't I one it goes over to the next
one and then out we'll cover anyway
equation okay
so let's go ahead and let's do that now
pause for a second don't write this next
part down this is one of the reasons why
the parametric equations are powerful
okay or there they will elevate it this
way what is the equation of this ellipse
see question
yes x squared a squared plus y squared
on B squared it was one okay now in
order to get this piece of information
just ask before they bring it right
I can't I'm gonna need to differentiate
this guy in some way okay by the way we
will but look it's a real mess like four
stanzas on function if it's in relation
so you're gonna get two derivatives or
two values for the move every point
where the ellipse exists that's kind of
big pain not to mention the fact that it
just all tangled up like the form that
we've chosen that makes the geometry of
the ellipse easiest to work with like
where's the major actors where's the
minor axis this is a nice form to
understand where all of those things are
like this this form of the equation of
the ellipse is really nice for that and
really sucky for calculus okay
so therefore like using the Cartesian
equation that's not where I'm going to
go first okay
now therefore I'm going to go to these
guys ok now this causes a minor problem
for us because those are our there's a
trig function that's right and we have
not dealt with the calculus of the trig
functions yeah we will deal with them at
well end of this term beginning of next
term but I'm just going to show you the
results for them I will give you a quick
visual intuition to validate the results
and then we're going to use them in a
similar way to how you know I talked
about something like this this result
you learn at year seven right the actual
math to prove that this is the case like
the rigors that you only let last year
after four whole years now you will not
have to wait this long to get the full
rigorous proofs for the derivatives of
these functions okay but you have to
wait a little bit alright so I'll decide
here and maybe in a separate color what
I'd like you to write for VP is the
derivatives of the two basic trig
functions
now we'll get these results under the
draw and you're gonna draw some very
very quick basic pictures which are not
a proof at all but just kind of like oh
yeah that makes sense
so a picture of science if you draw a
very little sketch of sine X just from
naught to 2 pi like so what conclusions
can you draw about the gradient function
of this graph right just by looking at
look just by doing a sort of basic idea
one of the quickest things you can see
just from when we did this and we said
here's a graph do the first 3 to the
second blue stuff is usually before
there are two stationary points so that
tells you the derivative at two two
points what are those values by the way
gradients radians
at PI no - there is a stationary point
and at three plan - is just another
stationary point right so that's good
I've got two points that I don't agree
it was positive at the same time I look
before this stationary point I say oh no
this gradient is positive and decreasing
right it's positive and kind of
decreasing down like that it has to come
down to zero at x equals one - yeah
what's going on how do you describe
what's happening in between of the two
stationary points what is the sign of
the derivative it's negative rights
negative it is a little bit negative
here it gets more and more negative up
till this point here and then it sort of
gets less negative and it gets shallow
again till you hit zero just the next
station at work does that make sense
let me say that again the derivative
it's gets negative and it gets
increasingly never did until it has to
come back up because it slows down it
gets to another stationary point and
then to finish it off what's happening I
mean he is kind of a reverse image of
what's happening over here I'm a
positive gradient so therefore the
derivative as have a positive side okay
now just on this quick visual what does
that gradient function look like to you
that looks a heck of a lot like cosine
to me so therefore we're actually going
to say just not our intuition right but
the derivative of sine is cos it is
exactly close and beyond the formal
proof for this is quite it's quite
beautiful baseball so we're not going to
address it now lastly again I will do
this one a bit quicker draw me a little
version
there are stationary points on cosine
right we've just drawn from Delta 2 pi
how many stationary points do you count
I count I cloud 1 2 3 stationary points
do you agree point to which I could draw
a horizontal tangent ok
so therefore the gradient function at
know what and and PI and to my the
gradient should be 0 all this puts them
here young and yeah yep
ok now let's have a look between the
first two stationary points
what's the sign of the derivative yeah
it's negative look the whole thing is
decreasing in this domain right it's I'm
doing the same thing it did up here
right it's like really really really
decreasing at that point but then it's
going to kind of slow it back down even
though it's still decreasing so I get to
a stationary and then every he it is the
exact same thing but backwards you've
got an increasing function from PI to 2
pi the steepest point is he that's when
it's moving the fastest that's steepest
right and then you've got to get back to
the stationary point so you sort of come
down like that what does that graph look
like
yeah it's sine X but of side down
ok so let's drag that down again this is
not a proof but it's intuitive enough
that you can see yeah okay that makes
sense